Speaker 1: Donald Trump announced yesterday
in a second disgusting video that on day one
of his next presidency, if he is to get one,
he will violate the Constitution of the United
States.
Trump loves the Constitution just like he
loves American flags and law and order and
all of these different things.
Trump loves the Constitution, and many of
his followers see it almost like a sacred
religious document.
And yet, Trump says on day one of his presidency,
if he is inaugurated in January of 2025, he
will sign an executive order ending birthright
citizenship as guaranteed by the 14th Amendment
to the Constitution of the United States.
Here is Donald Trump looking admittedly a
little confused.
Not clear he knows where he is or what he's
saying.
Take a listen to what he says.
Speaker 2: Plan to secure the border.
On day one of my new term in office, I will
sign an executive order making clear to federal
agencies that under the correct interpretation
of the law going forward, the future children
of illegal aliens will not receive automatic
U.S. citizenship.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Now, he says there according to some interpretations
of the law.
If you can find me serious legal experts who
believe that birthright citizenship could
be denied as written in the 14th Amendment,
please send me that.
Because all of the research I did this morning
matches up with my prior discussions with
legal experts on the matter, which is it is
very clearly part of the 14th Amendment.
Now, I want to focus in on one particular
aspect of this.
The right wingers cheerleading this idea and
birthright citizenship and anchor babies as
they like to call them.
Those right wingers should be very careful
about the unintended consequences that Trump
trying to do this could have.
First of all, it does appear it would violate
the Constitution and the Supreme Court precedent,
which established that there is a fundamental
right to citizenship if born in the United
States.
Right wingers claim to worship that document
as a religious text, and indeed, it appears
as though this is a fundamental right.
If they were to attempt this, it would be
potentially years and years and years of legal
conundrum, we might call it.
And in the immediate, it would much more quickly
increase the undocumented population in the
United States, which they claim to want to
reduce.
This is a really important thing.
If Trump ends birthright citizenship going
forward, then you are going to have a situation
where babies will be born here, will immediately
be undocumented, presumably subject to deportation,
and it will so instantly clog up and gum up
immigration processes that because you will
all of a sudden see authorities tied up with
looking at deporting newborn babies.
You actually might you know, they say that
we really care about criminal aliens, the
people committing crimes, etc., to the extent
that they exist and they do to a degree, but
just not to the degree that Donald Trump says
you are going to get in the way of actually
locating and deporting those individuals who
are only not only undocumented, but have committed
crimes because you are going to be focusing
on trying to deport newborn babies.
They are going to make the problem they want
to fix worse.
Secondly, it will impact the American economy.
It will reduce the labor force.
It will reduce the tax base.
It will reduce consumer demand by just getting
rid of people and their families, even if
they're babies and they're not spending their
own money.
You are going to push them as well as potentially
parents out of the United States.
You will reduce the tax base, reduce the labor
force and reduce consumer demand.
That's not good for the economy.
Years of legal challenges will also come with
them.
It will bring with them huge financial costs.
These claim to be fiscal conservatives, but
of course it will be extraordinarily expensive
and it will destroy international image of
the United States.
Now, that's not anything new.
You might remember that Gallup global surveys
about global opinion about the United States
bottomed out when Trump was president has
fortunately started to recover since Joe Biden
became president.
But again, the United States, for all of our
faults, the United States has been seen.
Generally not every part of the United States,
but generally the United States has been seen
as a nation that embraces immigrants, offers
opportunity to those born within its borders.
And if you end birthright citizenship, particularly
in this vindictive way, you're going to tarnish
that image, and then that will make it more
difficult to continue having the exact same
relationships diplomatically with our long
term allies.
There will be other countries affected by
the policy change on and on and on.
And there are question marks as to what such
a decision by Trump would do to national security
efforts.
And what I mean by that is that birthright
citizenship has implications for national
security because it says, okay, if you're
born here, you have a vested interest in the
country, you get citizenship.
That creates a tie.
If you end birthright citizenship for people
born here, you can create all sorts of different
security issues.
Legal gray areas, raise questions about rights
and obligations of individuals within the
country.
It's extraordinarily problematic in a number
of different ways.
Now, do we believe Trump will actually do
this on day one of his presidency?
I don't know.
I mean, I genuinely don't know.
Trump says a lot of things.
He told us in August of 2020 that we were
two weeks away from receiving his new health
care plan.
I'm still waiting for it.
I'm really curious what would be in there.
Maybe he met August of 2024.
I don't know at this point in time.
But will Trump actually do it?
Unclear.
Would this be a good idea?
No.
Would it even be constitutional?
Probably not.